[Música]
en 1796 thomas jefferson recibió una
caja de huesos que no pudo identificar
una garra larga y afilada le recordó a
un león pero los huesos del brazo
sugerían un animal más grande de unos
tres metros de largo
creyendo que podía ser una especie
enorme y desconocida de león de américa
del norte jefferson advirtió a los
exploradores louis y clark que tuvieran
cuidado con este misterioso depredador
pero la caja de huesos de jefferson no
provenía de un león venía de un perezoso
gigante ahora extinto los perezosos
prehistóricos aparecieron por primera
vez hace unos 35 millones de años
decenas de esta especie vivieron en
américa del norte central y del sur
junto a otras criaturas antiguas como
mastodontes y armadillos gigantes
algunos perezosos de tierra como el mega
lo líquido eran de tamaño gato pero
muchos eran enormes el perezoso de
jefferson megal onix pesaba cerca de una
tonelada y era pequeño en comparación
con el megaterio que podía alcanzar las
6 toneladas como un elefante
deambulaban por bosques y sabanas usando
sus fuertes brazos y afiladas garras
para arrancar raíces y trepar a los
árboles alimentándose de hierba hojas y
aguacates prehistóricos
de hecho podríamos no tener aguacates de
no ser por los perezosos gigantes
los animales más pequeños no podían
tragar la gran semilla del aguacate pero
los perezosos sí y así se expandieron
los árboles de aguacate
los perezosos terrestres prosperaron por
millones de años pero hace diez mil años
comenzaron a desaparecer junto con los
otros mamíferos gigantes del hemisferio
occidental
los investigadores creen que los
perezosos podrían haber sido expulsados
por una edad de hielo que se avecinaba o
competencia con otras especies quizás
seres humanos que llegaron a la región
cuando la mayoría de los perezosos se
extinguieron algunos de los perezosos
más pequeños sobrevivieron y emigraron a
las copas de los árboles hoy en día
quedan seis especies que viven en las
copas de los árboles de las selvas
tropicales de américa central y del sur
vivir en los árboles es una buena manera
de evitar a los depredadores y hay
muchas hojas para comer pero esta dieta
tiene sus inconvenientes los animales
extraen energía de los alimentos y usan
esa energía para moverse mantener su
temperatura corporal mantener sus
órganos funcionando y todas las demás
funciones necesarias para la
supervivencia
pero las hojas no contienen mucha
energía y la que tienen es fácil de
extraer
la mayoría de los herbívoros
complementan su dieta a base de hojas
con alimentos que aportan más energía
como frutas y semillas pero los
perezosos especialmente los perezosos de
tres dedos dependen de las hojas casi
exclusivamente han desarrollado
estrategias optimizadas para hacer
frente a esa dieta restringida
primero extraen tanta energía de su
alimento como sea posible
los perezosos tienen un estómago de
varias cámaras que ocupa un tercio de su
cuerpo y dependiendo de la especie
pueden pasar de cinco a siete días o
incluso semanas digiriendo una comida
la otra pieza del rompecabezas es usar
la menor energía posible una forma en
que los perezosos hacen esto por
supuesto es no moviéndose mucho pasan la
mayor parte de su tiempo comiendo
descansando o durmiendo descienden de
las copas una sola vez a la semana para
hacer sus necesidades
cuando los perezosos se mueven no son
muy rápidos un perezoso necesitaría unos
cinco minutos para cruzar una calle de
un barrio normal este enfoque sin prisas
sobre la vida significa que los
perezosos no necesitan mucho músculo de
hecho tienen un 30% menos de masa
muscular que otros animales de su tamaño
los perezosos también usan menos energía
para mantenerse calientes porque su
temperatura corporal puede fluctuar
alrededor de 5 grados celsius menos que
un reptil de sangre fría pero más que la
mayoría de los mamíferos
estas adaptaciones físicas y de conducta
reducen el gasto de energía del perezoso
o tasa metabólica
los perezosos de tres dedos tienen el
metabolismo más lento entre los
mamíferos lo sigue el panda gigante y
luego los perezosos de dos dedos
moverse lentamente ha permitido que los
perezosos prosperen en su hábitat de la
copa de los árboles pero también los
propios perezosos son un gran hábitat
para otros organismos incluyendo algas
que proporcionan un poco de camuflaje
adicional y tal vez incluso un aperitivo
puede que los perezosos ya no sean
gigantes pero eso no los hace menos
admirables
si desea conocer más criaturas
increíbles ideas fascinantes e historias
atrapantes suscríbase a td en español
manténgase conectado y tenga curiosidad
[Música]